hi herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF heute live
schön dass ihr dabei seid wir sprechen
heute mal wieder über den Krieg in der
Ukraine und über die russische Miliz die
nach dem Angriff auf einen Grenzposten
im russischen Belgorod fahren ein paar
Tagen jetzt weitere Angriffe ankündigt
viele Mitglieder dieser Gruppe die ihr
da gerade seht sollen Neonazis sein und
hier ja bestreitet daran beteiligt zu
sein und kündigt heute auch noch an die
lange erwartete ukrainische
Gegenoffensive die laufe bereits seit
ein paar Tagen wie sind all diese
Geschehnisse einzuordnen darüber wollen
wir heute sprechen zum einen mit dem
Militärexperten Gustav gressel und mit
ZDF Reporter Tim Kröger der für uns in
der Südukraine ist und natürlich wie
immer auch mit euch da draußen wenn ihr
Fragen an die Gäste habt oder einfach
eure Meinung zum Thema mit uns teilen
wollt dann tut das gerne direkt hier im
youtube-chat oder per Mail an die
Mailadresse die ihr gerade eingeblendet
seht aber
lasst uns zunächst noch mal bei dieser
Gruppe bleiben die sich russisches
freiwilligen Kopf nennt ihr Anführer ist
Dennis Nikitin ein bekanntes Gesicht der
rechtsextreme Hooliganszene und der hat
zu den weiteren geplanten Aktionen der
Gruppe das hier gesagt
the operation die Operation läuft weiter
so sollte man es formulieren sie hat
verschiedene Phasen Phase 1 betrachten
wir als erfolgreich sie ist jetzt vorbei
in Zukunft planen wir neue Gebiete in
Russland zu erobern sie alle sollten nur
ein bisschen Geduld haben und ein paar
Tage warten dann werden sie uns dort
wiedersehen
ja und über diese Gruppe diese Bewegung
und ihre Operation darüber waren wir
jetzt sprechen mit Gustav Kresse
herzlich willkommen hallo
ja das sind Putin Gegner aus Russland
die Russland teilweise angreifen was
weiß man denn zu diesem Zeitpunkt noch
über diese Gruppe wie setzt sich die
zusammen da sollen ja verschiedene
Gruppierungen zusammen auftreten
ja also es ist ein bisschen ein
heterogener Laden der eben gezeigte
Anführer Dennis Nikitin ob der auch für
alle spricht ist auch noch ein bisschen
unklar ist wie gesagt ein
Kleinkrimineller und
Neonazi ja kommt aus der Fußball
Hooliganszene saß in Ukraine in Haft
wegen Drogenhandel war früher auch mal
in Deutschland ich glaube hier sind
glaube ich auch Strafverfahren gegen ihn
anhängig also es ist nicht ganz seidener
Mensch es gibt in der Ukraine generell
mehrere Kräfte die mit russischen
staatsbürgen beschäftigt sind also
benannt sind das meistens sind
Überläufer aus Kriegsgefangenen aber
nicht alle schließen sich eben diesen
diesen Aktionen an dieses freiwilligen
Chores dazu muss man auch sagen ich
stehe dazu vermuten dass sie vom
militärischen Nachrichtendienst hier
[Musik]
wenn ich geleitet dann zumindest oder
zumindest angestellt werden um solche
Aktionen durchzuführen und das ist
natürlich waghalsig und dafür scheint
sich auch nicht jeder gerne herzugeben
für solche Aktionen deshalb greift man
natürlich auf diese diese Elemente
zurück
das ist optisch nicht sehr schön aber
der Ukraine wahrscheinlich in dieser
Situation egal
ich habe hier gerade schon mal einen
Blick in die Fragen unserer Community
geworfen und hier kommt schon direkt
eine Frage auf Youtube was halten denn
die Amerikaner und andere Unterstützer
der Ukraine von der Aktion immerhin ist
jetzt eine Anmerkung von mir treten
diese Gruppierung ja mit westlichen
Waffen in Russland auf ja also nicht
unbedingt Waffen sondern es sind
Fahrzeuge die zurückgelassen wurden sind
oder anscheinend zurückgelassen worden
sind die aus dem Westen kommen das ist
natürlich eine eine eher dumme Aktion
denn offiziell hat ja die Ukraine damit
nichts zu tun damit man die Rhetorik
nach die Russland 2014 in Bezug auf den
Dom was angewandt hat dass man sagt das
sind lokale Kräfte das sind
unzufriedene russische Bürger die sich
hier auflehnen wir damit eigentlich gar
nichts zu tun und Putin soll doch mit
seiner eigenen Leuten verhandeln
natürlich stellt sich eine Frage woher
kommen dann diese Fahrzeuge die gibt's
natürlich nicht auf jedem Bauernmarkt in
Russland oder zwei Putin 2014 behauptet
auf Bauernmärkten keine man können man
Kampfpanzer kaufen weil man es besorgt
der Bürger in londas Fahrt
und ich schätze also offiziell gibt es
noch keine Reaktion dazu
der Sprecher des Weißen Hauses Chemie
sagt man wird das Untersuchen ich
schätze mal dass hinter verschlossenen
Türen da schon der eine oder andere böse
anrufen nach Kiew ging und Kiew
aufgefordert hat das einzustellen bzw
das nicht mit westlichen Gerät zu
vollführen generell muss man sagen es
macht aus Sicht der Ukraine militärisch
schon sind solche Aktionen durchzuführen
sie zwingen Russen die Russen Kräfte aus
der Kräne abzuziehen und diese Grenze
militärisch zu sichern das kostet Kräfte
das kostet Soldaten die sich dann auf
einer
mehr als 1000 km langen Grenze verteilen
deshalb sieht man natürlich im Westen
auch dass es theoretisch Sinn macht nur
wie gesagt man könnte intelligenter
Fahrzeuge einsetzen und man könnte
natürlich die Optik schönen wenn man
andere Leute nehmen würde oder zumindest
einen Sprecher
das behauptet der Anführer dieser Gruppe
die mir gerade gesehen haben Nikitin der
behauptet die hätten die Fahrzeuge von
Russen z.B aus Kämpfen rund um und in
Bach Mut und außerdem könnte man die
auch auf dem Schwarzmarkt kaufen die
glaubhaft ist sowas
das ist eher weniger glaubhaft also das
Gerät russischen Kräften in jene
gefallen ist das stimmt zu einem
gewissen Teil allerdings meistens in
zerstörten Zustand
es sind keine Bilder jetzt von größeren
intakten Kolonnen an Gerät bekannt die
russischen Kräften direkt in die Hände
gefallen wären und wenn dann werden
solche Exponate noch nach Russland
verfrachtet um um sie dort weiter zu
untersuchen dass man denen am
Schwarzmarkt handhabig wird ist ist
äußerst unwahrscheinlich
in Ukraine gibt es unter
Anführungszeichen private haben wie es
aus solchen amerikanischen Militär
Lieferungen da das weiß ich aus eigener
Erfahrung selber also eigentlich noch im
alten Krieg im dombas mal auf einer
Reise war dort mit ukrainischen Fahrern
unterhalten und die mir damals erzählt
hat glaube ich 2018 dass diese amerikan
Menschen haben wir es in so einem
schlechten Zustand waren dass die aus
Afghanistan kamen und schon so gebraucht
waren dass im Grunde Schrott waren und
das sozusagen der Deal war dass die
Kraftfahrer an diesen Fahrzeugen die
Reparaturen selber vornehmen und auf
eigene Kosten vornehmen und dafür sich
diese Fahrzeuge nach ihrem Turnus im
dombas mitnehmen durften also daraus ist
zu schließen dass zumindest eine gewisse
Anzahl dieser Fahrzeuge am
ukrainischen Markt am Privatmarkt gibt
oder gäbe allerdings wie gesagt die
diese freiwilligenchor sollte er
eigentlich darstellen dass es dass es
sich um einheimische Russen handeln
würde und dann fragt man sich auch was
machen die
ukrainischen
Gebrauchtwagenmarkt das ist als
Geschichte einfach nicht stimmig das
sollte man wenn man solche Operationen
führt ändern
ja zumindest sagen diese Operationen ja
aktuell für Aufmerksamkeit und wir haben
hier gleich mehrere Fragen aus der
Community dazu zum einen woher will
Russland jetzt die Truppen holen um die
Grenzen zu sichern und dann auch damit
verbunden ist Putin jetzt eigentlich in
seiner Macht gefährdet durch diese
Aktion
also das Putin in seiner Macht gefährdet
ist glaube ich zu direkt nicht aber es
ist natürlich hoch peinlich für ihn und
er muss reagieren er kann sich das nicht
gefallen lassen dass solche Aktionen
weitergehen deshalb wird der Soldaten
aus der Ukraine abziehen müssen und an
die Grenze Stellen
grenzschutzeinheiten des FSB sind an
sich zu schwach um solchen vorstoßen
etwas entgegenzusetzen dazu brauchst
Panzerabwehrwaffen man muss auch für
solche Leute wieder zurückzutreiben dann
für Gegenstöße auch Artillerie und
Panzerfahrzeuge einsetzen
diese aus der Ukraine abzuziehen ist
natürlich bitter für die russische Armee
die werden dort gebraucht um die
erwartete ukrainische Gegner Offensive
abzuwehren und er muss auch in Russland
Reserven stationieren um eben auf auf
mögliche Einbrüche eben zu reagieren all
das ist ein bisschen ein Spiegelbild von
dem Ausland im Winter gemacht hat wenn
wir uns zurück erinnern an den Dezember
an den besser als die erwartete
russische Winteroffensive losging da hat
Russland Manöver ein Belarus abgehalten
an der ukrainischen Grenze da gab es
viele Fragen wird bei der Russe in den
Krieg mit eintreten etc das hat die
Ukraine dazu gezwungen starke Kräfte
auch im Westen des Landes
zurückzubehalten die belarussische
Grenze zu sichern all diese Kräfte
konnten nicht im Donbass wo dann die
russische Offensive Stadt von
verteidigen und genau dasselbe versucht
jetzt die Ukraine eben auch Russland
aufzuzwingen diese Grenze eben stärker
militärisch zu sichern damit man dann in
der Ukraine selber bei dieser Gegend
Offensive mehr Raum zur Verfügung hat um
zu manövrieren und durchstöße leichter
erzielen kann
sie haben es eben schon angesprochen
lang erwartete gegen Offensive darüber
wollen wir jetzt einmal sprechen wir
sprechen uns gleich noch mal und wollen
mal so ein bisschen auf die Meldung des
heutigen Tages gucken heute hat nämlich
ein selenski Berater im italienischen
Fernsehen folgendes gesagt
die Gegend Offensive dauert bereits seit
Tagen an es ist ein intensiver Krieg
über eine 1.500 km lange Grenze aber die
Aktionen haben bereits begonnen
ja das hat heute viele Menschen so ein
bisschen überrascht wenn ihr häufiger
mal ZDF heute live guckt wisst ihr dass
wir ja hier schon seit Wochen darüber
rätseln ob diese Offensive jetzt schon
begonnen hat ob sie erst in Planung ist
oder ob sie stückweise beginnt was
dieses Statement bedeutet und wie es den
Menschen im Süden der Ukraine damit geht
darüber spreche ich jetzt mit meinem
zdf-kollegen Tim Kröger der uns live aus
saborida zugeschaltet ist hallo Tim
schönen guten Abend Tim wie blickst du
denn auf dieses Statement heute und wie
kann man das einordnen
naja also das war ja der Präsidenten
Berater podoljak der gesagt hat dass
diese Offensive im Grunde schon seit
einigen Tagen läuft und ich denke wenn
er das sagt dann kann man das auch so
jetzt für verbrieft nehmen ich denke es
ist eine Frage der Definition und diese
Definition hat der mehr oder weniger
auch dann auf Twitter noch mal
nachgelegt er hat gesagt man darf sich
diese Offensive nicht so vorstellen als
würde da praktisch mit einem gong-schlag
an einem bestimmten Tag zu einer
bestimmten Uhrzeit eine Kolonne
losfahren und das ist dann die Offensive
sondern es sei eben eine dass ein
mehrere dutzende verschiedene
Operationen Aktionen entlang dieser
hunderte Kilometer langen Frontlinie er
hat nicht genau gesagt was das für
Aktionen sind also beispielsweise ob das
etwa die vorstütze sind die wir derzeit
an den Flanken vom Bach Mut sehen auf
Seiten der ukrainischen Armee oder ob
vielleicht wirklich dieser Angriff von
Belgorod dazu gehört auch wenn die
ukrainische Führung immer wieder betont
dass sie damit überhaupt nichts zu tun
hat in deinem letzten Punkt aber in
Deinem Tweet ist er durchaus noch mal
konkret und zwar hat er gesagt dass
diese Aktionen hinter der Front also
hinter der russischen Front die Angriffe
auf Infrastruktur der Russen dass das
eben schon Teil der ukrainischen
Offensive sein und das haben wir
tatsächlich in den vergangenen Wochen
immer wieder gesehen beispielsweise
Angriffe auf
Treibstoffdepots auf Munitionsdepots auf
Infrastruktur Eisenbahnanlagen auch mit
der neu gelieferten Rakete Storm ist
Storm Shadow also das ist dann wirklich
so wenn der präsidentenberater sagt das
gehört alles zu dieser Gegend Offensive
dann in der Tat hat sie begonnen
allerdings ist natürlich schon die Frage
ob es nicht womöglich noch eine zweite
Phase dieser Offensive dann gibt ähm wo
ist denn wirklich doch um signifikante
Gelände Gewinne gibt wir dürfen nicht
verraten vergessen dass wir in den
vergessen in den vergangenen Tagen und
Wochen immer wieder gehört haben dass
Zehntausende von neuen Soldatinnen und
Soldaten auf ukrainischer Seite
ausgebildet worden sind ganze Brigaden
sind neu aufgestellt worden eben auch
immer wieder
wohl für diese Offensive diese Soldaten
und Soldaten sind auch ausgebildet
worden im sogenannten Kampf der
gebundenen Waffen also in einem Kampf wo
man mit verschiedenen Waffengattungen
zusammen signifikante Erfolge erzielen
kann dazu kommt noch das
Nato-Generalsekretär Stoltenberg gesagt
hat dass 230 Kampfpanzer geliefert
worden sind mehr als 1.500 gepanzerte
Fahrzeuge also die Frage ist kommen
diese denn noch zum zum Einsatz
beispielsweise in einem größeren Angriff
hier in saporizischer südlich von hier
wir viele vermuten da ginge es zum
Beispiel dann dabei darum durchzustoßen
bis zum Meer bis zur Stadt militopol und
dann dabei die Verbindung zwischen
Russland und der von Russland
annektierten
Halbinsel Krim zu durchbrechen das wäre
militärisch gesehen schon ein ziemlicher
Schlag gegen die russische Seite das
könnte zum Beispiel ein so ein Vorschuss
sein bei dem ich eigentlich davon
ausgehe dass es schon ein größerer damit
auf sein müsste ganz einfach deswegen
weil die russische Seite in den
vergangenen Monaten die
Verteidigungslinien massiv ausgebaut hat
also das müssen hunderte von
Metern sein die dazu überwinden sind
Minenfelder Schützengräben Panzergräben
und das lässt sich sicherlich nicht mit
kleinen Nadelstichen machen also ja laut
der Definition die der
präsidentenberater podoljak jetzt im
Moment sozusagen uns gegeben hat ist
diese Offensive am laufen zumindest eine
erste Phase aber eben die Frage ist
schon ob es nicht noch mal eine weitere
gibt wo es dann um sie nicht bekannte
Gelände geht
ja also vielleicht noch größere Angriffe
erwartet gerade weil auch so viele
Soldaten auf ukrainischer Seite
ausgebildet wurden und werden und mit
einigen von den hast du ja in den
letzten Tagen und Wochen gesprochen wie
geht es den aktuellen wie blicken die
auf die Situation
genau wir waren hier vor einigen Tagen
bei einem Training von Soldaten das
waren größtenteilsoldaten die schon
gekämpft haben also das waren jetzt
nicht
Soldaten zu die zu diesem Brigaden
gehört haben die jetzt ganz offenbar neu
ausgebildet werden das muss man sich so
vorstellen dass diese Soldaten für
einige Tage sich von der Front
zurückziehen ins Hinterland weit ins
Hinterland und dann da eben
Schießtraining machen sich in der Ersten
Hilfe großen auffrischen lassen und dass
diese Soldaten sich auch einfach ein
bisschen ausruhen und wir konnten da
Filmen und hatten eben dabei auch die
Möglichkeit mit einigen dieser Soldaten
ins Gespräch zu kommen und einer hat uns
erzählt dass viele Soldaten natürlich
mittlerweile ganz schön erschöpft sind
viele dieser Soldaten haben tatsächlich
unmittelbar am 24.02 22 oder in den
Tagen und Wochen danach sich zur Armee
gemeldet kämpfen seither und haben auch
nur wenige Tage frei also nur wenig
Möglichkeiten beispielsweise ihre
Familien zu sehen mal für einige Tage
nach Hause zu kommen und das muss
natürlich
wirklich zermürbend sein zum einen für
die Familien aber zum anderen auch für
die Soldaten selbst dieser Soldat
beispielsweise hat uns auch erzählt dass
er es ganz besonders traurig findet dass
sein Sohn in all dieser Zeit ohne ihn
aufwächst und beziehungsweise eher auch
seinen Sohn in all dieser Zeit nicht
sehen kann und dazu muss man auch wissen
dass viele dieser Soldaten die sich da
gemeldet hatten haben vor dem 24.02 22
nicht unbedingt ein militärischen
Hintergrund hatten sondern dass das
Menschen waren die einem ganz normalen
Beruf nachgegangen sind
die ein ganz normales Leben gelebt haben
dass dann auf einmal wirklich durch
diesen Krieg auf den Kopf gestellt
worden ist und ich hatte persönlich auch
den Eindruck und das haben sie uns zum
Teil auch gesagt dass sie jetzt auch
wirklich auf diese Offensive setzen dass
sie auf diese Offensive hoffen dass
viele von ihnen endlich wieder die
Initiative in diesen kann ähm ergreifen
wollen weil man muss sich vorstellen
dass die ukrainische Seite ja im Grunde
seit den erfolgreichen offensiven von
Carson im Süden und Rake im Norden im
vergangen en Jahr seit Monaten mehr oder
weniger im Verteidigungsmodus ist und es
ist natürlich zermürbend und deswegen
hatte ich eben den Eindruck dass viele
dieser Soldaten und Soldaten jetzt
wirklich wieder nach vorne gehen wollen
die Initiative ergreifen wollen und dass
viele natürlich auch hoffen dass diese
Offensive dann in ihrem Sinne
erfolgreich sein wird
ja und jetzt bist du ja in saporisha
also im Süden der Ukraine wo vielleicht
auch erwartet wird dass es mit dieser
Offensive losgeht was bedeutet das denn
für die Menschen die dort aktuell noch
leben also ganz normales ganz normal wie
man das in dem Kontext sagen kann Leben
führen wie geht's den
also tatsächlich
normales einigermaßen normales Leben
hier in der etwas größeren Stadt
saporicia ja durchaus wir sind ja aber
bestimmt noch 70 60 70 km von der Front
entfernt wenn man dann allerdings und
das haben wir gemacht vor zwei Tagen
weiter nach vorne fährt in die
sogenannten Orte an der Front an die
Frau in die Front der Vater z.B dann ist
der Krieg allgegenwärtig dort die ist
noch ungefähr fünf Kilometer von der
Front entfernt wir sind da hingefahren
mit einer lokal Journalistin die es
geschafft hat nach einem Jahr Pause ihre
Zeitung noch mal hier in SAP produzieren
zu lassen und die dann in diese Front
Dörfer zu bringen um eben vor allem den
älteren Menschen auch Informationen zu
bringen und wir sind dann mit ihr
zusammengefahren sind mit diesen älteren
Menschen ins Gespräch gekommen und was
wirklich fast schon etwas erschüttern
war aber das ganz viele dieser Menschen
sehr schnell angefangen haben zu weinen
entweder weil sie Angehörige verloren
haben oder weil das Haus zerstört worden
ist oder einfach weil ihre Haus unsere
massiv unter diesem Krieg leiden dazu
kommt auch noch dass dieser
gefechtslam relativ allgegenwärtig ist
zu dem Zeitpunkt als wir da waren
beispielsweise ist auch ein eine Rakete
relativ nah über unsere Köpfe hinweg
geflogen also diese Menschen dort in
diesem permanenten Beschuss weil sie so
nah an der Front sind ausgesetzt und das
zermürbt sie natürlich unfassbar die
Vize-Bürgermeisterin von eure Kiefer hat
uns auch gesagt dass viele jetzt hoffen
dass diese Offensive kommen und auch
erfolgreich sein wird um eben die
russische Front die Russen weiter
wegzudrücken von vom Ort oritiv damit
eben diese Artillerie Beschuss nicht
mehr einfach so möglich ist und und
damit eben auch aufhört dass diese Stadt
oder dieser Ort weiter zerstört wird
weil natürlich sieht man das nicht nur
merkt man das nicht nur den Menschen an
sondern man sieht es auch in der Stadt
man fährt durch die Stadt die es
Menschen leer und man sieht unglaublich
verzieht viele zerstörte Häuser und zwar
so zerstört wie ich es eigentlich nur
von Orten kenne wo wirklich auch
Straßenkämpfe stattgefunden haben also
die Menschen dort hoffen dass jetzt
demnächst sich etwas tut das in
irgendeiner Art und Weise durch diese
jetzt schon laufende oder noch kommende
utensive die russische Freund die mit
Russland weiter weggedrückt wird
ja danke Tim für diese wirklich
bedrückenden Eindrücke von vor Ort
und über diese vielleicht schon laufende
vielleicht noch stärker kommende
Offensive die heute angekündigt wurde
spreche ich jetzt auch noch mal mit
Polizei noch mal mit Militärexperte
Gustav gressel der mir wieder
zugeschaltet ist Herr gräße wie
interpretieren sie denn diese Äußerung
von podoljak heute
eben schon angeklungen hat dass es eine
Frage der Definition also wir sind in
der Vorbereitungsphase der Offensive die
kann man natürlich zur Offensive dazu
zählen aber in dieser Phase geht es in
erster Linie darum dass die Ukraine die
Reaktionsmöglichkeiten der russischen
Seite auf einen Vorstoß soweit wie
möglich einschränkt und dazu gehören zum
einen mal Täuschungsmanöver um eine
Umgruppierung der russischen Kräfte zu
erzwingen oder sie zur dazu zu verleiten
das sind also Angriffe in falsche
Richtung in Stör Aktionen ähnlich wie
wir das eben im Belgorod gesehen haben
dann natürlich Angriffe auf die
führungsinfrastruktur des Gegners auf
die Logistikinfrastruktur also
Munitionsdepots Treibmittel Depots auf
die Verkehrsinfrastruktur Eisenbahnen
Straßenbrücken etc damit wenn die
Offensive kommt oder wenn der Angriffe
die Angriffsphase die durchbruchsphase
dieser Offensive beginnt
dass dann eben die russische Armee mit
den Kräften falsch steht und mit den
Kräften mit denen sie richtig steht
nicht zeitgerecht reagieren kann weil
eben das entsprechende Kommando Weg ist
weil Reserven nicht da sind weil
Munition nicht mehr da ist weiter
Treibstoff fehlt in der Phase sehen wir
jetzt und wir sehen das ja auch mit den
ganzen Angriffen im Hinterland mit den
Drohnenangriffen mit dem Einsatz von
Storm Shadow dass man hier eben genau in
diesem Punkten arbeitet war natürlich
die durchbruchsphase beginnen wird ist
schwer zu sagen die hängt von vielen
Dingen ab in die wir im Westen überhaupt
keinen Einblick haben einer davon ist
Logistik die Ukraine hält Kräfte bereit
die größer sind als die Landstreitkräfte
der Bundeswehr
das sind enorme Mengen an Munition an
Sprit die hier für so eine offensive
notwendig sein müssen
munitionskäufe da gab es Verhandlungen
noch bis in April hinein von
verhandlungsabschluss bis zur
Auslieferung von Munition dauert halt
auch noch eine gewisse Zeit bis diese
diese nachschubgüter dann auch in in
vorderen Positionen sind damit man sich
schneller abgreifen kann dauert das eine
Zeit bis alle westlichen Geräte da sind
bis die Soldaten nicht nur auf den
Geräten selber gut ausgebildet sind
sondern auch im Team zusammen spielen
mit anderen Waffen das eingespieltes
daraus eine gewisse Zeit alle diese
Vorbereitungen muss die Ukraine
abschließen bevor sie wirklich Lust
schlagen kann und diese Zeit nutzte eben
durch diese mit diesen
Vorbereitungsarbeiten Schläge gegen die
Tiefe ablenken sondern über
ja zum Thema gegen offensiver habe ich
hier gerade noch eine Frage eben Chat
und zwar fragt Ecke auf Youtube was wird
Putin noch tun um die ukrainische gegen
Offensive aufzuhalten
Russland bereitet sich seit Monaten
darauf vor indem es vor allen Dingen
Stellungen ausgräbt also
Schützengräben Stellungen für Panzer
davor gestaffelt sperren also panzerigel
betontsperren Panzergräben Minenfelder
das Problem dass die russische Seite
dabei hat ist dass man diese Sperren
auch immer durch Feuer überwachen muss
das heißt ich muss Soldaten ich muss
Gerät Panzer Artillerie in der Nähe
haben die auf die Ukraine schießen
würden wenn sie diese diese Sperren
beseitigen wollen und da hat Russland
das Problem ist es mittlerweile wieder
so ausgedünnt ist mit seinen Kräften
dass man eben nicht die ganze Front
durchgehend und gut besetzen kann und
das ist ja auch der Grund warum die
Ukraine diese Ablenkungsmanöver machen
wenn Sie die Russen dazu zwingen diese
Front noch weiter auszudünnen dann sind
diese Hindernisse so technisch imposant
sie sind wirklich Giganten auf Tönen den
Füßen weil eben ohne überwachen des
Feuer ohne Truppen in den Schützen
Gräben die Schützen Gräben selber wenig
wert sind das zweite was man sich fragt
im Westen ist natürlich die Rolle der
russischen Luftwaffe die bis jetzt im
Krieg keine große Rolle gespielt hat die
aber noch intakt ist also die Verluste
an Panzern und Schützenpanzern etc die
sind ja enorm die sind auch dokumentiert
aber die Verluste an Flugzeugen an
Kampfflugzeugen halten sich noch in
geringen Maße die Verluste am Piloten
sind noch geringer weil die meistens aus
diesen Maschinen
unversehrt oder ein leicht verletzt
ausgestiegen sind und in Gefangenen
austauschen noch schnell
sozusagen ausgetauscht werden das heißt
die Frage wie aktiv wird die russische
Luftwaffe hier gegen vorgehen wie oft
muss dann die ukrainische Jagdwaffe
ausrücken um eben den Bodentruppen
sozusagen die gegnerischen
Kampfflugzeuge irgendwie vom Hals zu
halten das sind spannende Fragen das
sind auch
ist auch der Grund warum die Ukraine in
den letzten Wochen und Monaten ja schon
so einen Druck ausgeübt hat auf den
Westen Kampfflugzeuge freizugeben F16 zu
liefern weil man eben Angst hat dass ich
über den Sommer über den Verlauf dieser
Offensive die ukrainische Jagdwaffe doch
stark abnutzen könnte
ja und wir haben hier noch ein paar
Fragen zum Thema Offensive die ich gerne
stellen würde Daniel schwarz fragt auf
Youtube würde es nicht Sinn machen für
die Ukraine größere Truppenverbände in
die Nähe der russischen Grenze zu
verlegen damit Russland gezwungen wird
Truppen aus den umkämpften Gebieten
dorthin zu verlegen
ja das kann man machen die die Frage ist
da wie schaut's mit der ukrainischen
Transportkapazität aus bzw
wie wie stark Willi Ukraine wenn Sie die
eisenbahntransportkapazität für größere
Verbände gleichzeitig nicht hat ihre
Kräfte auf dem auf dem landMasch
beanspruchen im Grunde kann die Ukraine
das machen weil sie auf der sogenannten
inneren Linie kämpft das heißt um
Verbände von Norden nach Süd zu verlegen
kann sie durch eigenes Land fahren hat
einen kurzen Weg die Russen müssen ganz
außen rum müssen auch noch um die
Reichweite von Heimat Raketen sausen ich
denke nur dass bei Verlegungen an die
russische Grenze selber Putin sich denkt
ein ein Angriff nach Russland ist
unwahrscheinlich weil der Westen er das
im Grunde der Ukraine untersagt hat auch
bei diesen Stör Aktionen dieser
russischen freiwilligen streitet ja die
Ukraine jede Beteiligung ab und sagt das
sind alles russische Staatsbürger wir
haben mit denen nichts zu tun
ja das geht bei solchen freiwilligen das
würde aber natürlich nicht gehen wenn da
ukrainische Brigaden geschlossen über
die Grenze sausen aber solche Dinge kann
man natürlich machen wenn man zum
Beispiel in einem Abschnitt der Front
angreift oder einen großen Angriff
vortäuscht und diesen Angriff nach
relativ kurzer Zeit wieder abbricht um
eben dann
an einen anderen Sektor zu verlegen und
dort dann auch wirklich durchzustoßen
dann würde auf der russischen Seite man
schon reagieren Reserven verlegen sich
vorbereiten denken das ist der der
Durchstoß und dann war es doch nicht
solche
Ereignisse können wir nahe Zukunft
wahrscheinlich oft erleben deshalb auch
bei der Berichterstattung wäre ich immer
Vorsicht selbst wenn sozusagen wenn man
in der Früh aufwacht und man fährt von
großen ukrainischen Durchbrüchen das
kann sich relativ schnell auch dann
wieder auflösen weil eben solche
Täuschungsmanöver Teil dieser
Vorbereitungsphase sind
ja diese Vorbereitungsphase
beziehungsweise die Offensive war in den
letzten Wochen ja ganz großer Teil der
Bericht Erstattung immer wieder war das
aber auch die Stadt Bach Mut ähm auch
weil die Wagner seltener Truppe dort vor
Ort war und die Stadt eingenommen hat
jetzt da sehen wir noch mal auf der
Karte wo bachmut liegt jetzt hat die
wagnergruppe angekündigt sie wollen
diese Stadt verlassen und die aktuelle
Situation in bachmut hat Thomas Gonzi
auch für uns zusammengefasst
bachmut joviale Begrüßung im Krieg der
Chef der berüchtigten Söldnergruppe
Wagner besucht seine Männer seine
Botschaft an sie und alle die diese
Bilder sehen Stimmung gut Auftrag
erfüllt
wir ziehen unsere Einheiten aus bachmut
zurück bis zum 1 Juni werden wir wieder
in unserer Basis sein wir übergeben
unsere Stellungen und Munition ans
Militär
so sah sie vor dem Krieg aus die
Kleinstadt im Osten der Ukraine mit
einstmals 74.000 Einwohnern und das ist
bachmut nun völlig zerstört nach 9
monatigen kämpfen und jetzt angeblich
komplett eingenommen ein Ort mit
begrenzter strategischer aber hoher
symbolischer Bedeutung
ja und diese berühmten Wagner Truppen
sollen jetzt abgezogen werden sagt ihr
Führer brigochien welche Auswirkungen
hätte das auf bachmut wenn jetzt diese
seltener Truppen durch reguläre
russische Truppen ersetzt würden
immer vorsichtig sein er hat schon
vieles angekündigten seinem Leben das
dann nicht zu war
wovon ausgehen kann ist dass er selber
sich zurückzieht und das ist sein Label
Wagner zurückzieht auch weil er
natürlich im Hintergrund spürt dass es
von nun an zurückgeht und das er
sozusagen dafür oder mit dieser
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so glorreichen
Phase des Krieges persönlich nicht mehr
so viel zu tun haben will ob alle Wagner
Söldner abgezogen werden vor allen
Dingen in die Strafgefangenen die man
rekrutiert haben bleibt frage ich die
russische Armee hat ja mittlerweile
eigene Strafgefangenen Einheiten
aufgestellt die könnte da könnten also
diese wagenkämpfe auch in diese einfach
überführt werden dann bleiben sie vor
Ort nur das Label ändert sich in dem
Sinn wie gesagt würde ich würde ich noch
mal noch mal schauen was was wirklich
passiert in den nächsten Tagen
jetzt hat sich ja in den letzten Wochen
immer wieder die Frage gestellt wie
wichtig ist bachmut denn eigentlich noch
hat diese Stadt noch eine große
Bedeutung oder ist das mittlerweile auch
mehr ein ja eine symbolische Bedeutung
die Bedeutung der Stadt ist mittlerweile
rein symbolisch also die Schlacht Umbach
Mut die dauert nun länger als die
Schlacht um Stalingrad gedauert hat
bachmut ist jetzt in aller Welt bekannt
ist in dem Sinne einem Prestige Objekt
für die russische Armee die sozusagen
einen Punkt setzen will dass eben noch
Gelände einnehmen kann aber militärisch
hat sie hat sie keinen Wert und und viel
wirtschaftlich natürliche sie komplett
zerstört also ukrainischer Sicht hat man
in bachmut dadurch dass sie ebenso einen
symbolischen Wert hat die Chance dass
man russische Truppen wieder fixiert das
Spiel auch Zusammenhang mit der Gegend
Offensive eine Rolle also die Ukraine
hält starke Höhen Stellungen westlich
von bachmut und hat auch ihre Stellungen
südlich und nördlich davon verbesserter
steht man auf Hügeln wo man Nachbar Mut
reinschauen kann auch von dort
Artillerie gut die regieren kann das
kann man nutzen um russische Truppen
dort zu fixieren das ist nicht
wegbewegen können auch das Russland
gezwungen sein wird dort noch Truppen
starke Truppen zu stationieren damit
eben die Ukraine diese Stadt nicht
einkesselt oder nicht zurückholen kann
aber das fixiert russische Truppen dort
wahrscheinlich würde die gegen Offensive
dann auf einem anderen Ort erfolgen und
ist sozusagen diese Fixierung der
russischen Truppen ist ist für die
Ukraine vorteilhaft über das hinaus hat
die Stadt keinen Wert mehr
und wir haben noch eine Frage aus der
Community und zwar frag gunnarbock auf
Facebook wenn Russland mehr und mehr in
Bedrängnis gebracht wird wie groß ist
eigentlich die Gefahr das Putin eine
taktische Nuklearwaffe einsetzt
vielleicht auch in Verbindung mit der
Meldung die es gab dass Russland mit der
Verlegung von Atomwaffen nach Belarus
begonnen hat
also die Verlegung von taktischen
Atomwaffen nach Belarus hat einen
anderen Zusammenhang also das war ein
langes ein langer Wunsch von Alexander
Lukaschenka der sozusagen eine
Rückversicherung haben will das Russland
für ihn da ist und nicht fallen lassen
davor davor hatte Angst wenn russischer
turmbomben auf belarussischen Boden sind
dann ist es sich relativ sicher dass
sozusagen Russland ihn nicht unter den
Tisch wirft und auch bei Instabilität
bei möglichen Revolten oder Aufständen
gegen ihn
Truppen entsenden will einfach weil es
dieser Atomwaffen sichern will egal was
in Belarus passiert
umgekehrt ist es für Russland ein
verhandlungsschip mit dem Westen man
kann später etwa bei rüstungskontrollen
Verhandlungen dann immer diese
Atomwaffen im Belarus ins Felde führen
und Zugeständnisse im Westen zu
erpressen beziehungsweise einfach in
Verhandlungen einzutauschen was den
Einsatz von taktischen Atomwaffen in der
Ukraine angeht bin ich sehr skeptisch
und ich sie bis jetzt auch keine
Anzeichen dass sowas passiert das erste
wäre militärisch also militärisch ist
dieser Krieg nicht durch den Einsatz von
einer Atomwaffe
zu gewinnen sondern
da müsste Russland mehrere einsetzen
weil die ukrainischer Meer über einen
riesigen frontbogen verteilt ist
sehr dezentralisiert ist da da schlagt
man mit einer Waffe relativ wenig Kräfte
viele Atomwaffen gleichzeitig einsetzen
halte ich für relativ unwahrscheinlich
der politische
Fallout von so etwas für Russland der
wirtschaftliche Fallout wer gigantisch
man denke sich die Position Chinas das
ganz klar und eindeutig gegen einen
Atomwaffeneinsatz Russlands ist auch
Indien ist dementsprechend
nicht gewählt so etwas durchgehen lassen
und Russland ist jetzt wirtschaftlich
nachdem der Westen ja Russland stark
statt sanktioniert hat eben auf genau
diese Staaten angewiesen
psychologisch sozusagen einer Atomwaffe
gegen eine ukrainische Stadt würde die
Ukraine auch nicht aus dem Krieg werfen
das wäre es gibt so viele ukrainische
Städte die mittlerweile komplett
zerstört werden wenn wir uns allein
bachmut Anschauen dieser Schaden der an
dieser Stadt entsteht das wäre etwa mit
einer taktischen Atomwaffe dasselbe und
die haben auch die Ukraine nicht aus dem
Krieg geworfen das heißt die Vorstellung
man könnte das sozusagen mit einem
Einsatz diesen Schock herbeiführen die
ist auch nicht begründet war und
die dann wieder die diplomatischen
Folgekosten für Putin schwer abzusehen
abgesehen davon von Drohungen der USA
dann die entsprechende militärische
Unterstützung für die Ukraine noch
weitaus größer auszuweiten also unterm
Strich schaut so eine Rechnung für Putin
immer negativ aus und
auch wenn er sich oft sehr kalkuliert
in dieser Sache ist er bis jetzt immer
rational geblieben und man muss auch
sagen seitdem seitdem sich diese
Kalkulation stark zu Ungunsten Russlands
verschoben hat ist er mit den Drohungen
vom Atomwaffeneinsatz auch immer weiter
zurückgerudert die waren noch relativ
häufig letztes Jahr im Frühling bis in
den Sommer hinein dann um die Annexion
und die
die
teilmobil machen aber seitdem vor allen
Dingen aus der Deckung ging und sage wir
würden so etwas nicht dulden ist man da
zumindest aus offizieller Stelle in
Russland relativ leise geworden das
russische Fernsehen natürlich breit noch
mit Atomwaffen Einsatz hier und dort und
überall aber die sind ja für solche
Einsätze auch nicht zuständig die machen
nur Propaganda
und abschließend gibt es noch mal eine
größere Frage aus der Community die
vielleicht schon ein Stück in die
Zukunft schaut da fragt jemand auf
Youtube was macht der Westen wenn die
gegen Offensive über die ja jetzt viel
gesprochen haben der Ukraine scheitert
das ist eine gute Frage das ist eine
sehr berechtigte Frage weil viele Dinge
über die wir reden wie weit die gegen
Offensive gehen könnte sind
Wahrscheinlichkeiten die sind keine
Sicherheiten man hat im Krieg und bei
solchen militärischen Operationen nie
eine Sicherheit das etwas gut gehen kann
auch gute Kommandeure können mal einen
schlechten Tag haben können falsche
Informationen bekommen können sich
verkalkulieren verschätzen es kann immer
was in die Hose gehen
wenn diese Offensive entweder schief
geht oder auch unter ihren Erwartungen
bleibt
stellt sich für den Westen schon ein
gewisses Problem weil ich derzeit keine
großen Planungen sehe über diese
Offensive hinaus die allgemeine
Erwartung ist die Offensive gibt gut und
nachher wird Russland mit der Ukraine
verhandeln und die Ukraine ist in einer
starken Verhandlungsposition
ich bin zwar relativ zuversichtlich was
die Offensive selber angeht also die
Chancen dass sie gut geht ist eigentlich
besser als
dass sie schlecht geht aber trotzdem
wird wahrscheinlich Putin dann mit dem
Essen oder mit der Ukraine nicht
verhandeln genauso wie er jetzt nicht
verhandeln will weil er diesen Krieg auf
Zeit angelegt hat und einfach sieht dass
in der Rüstungsproduktion in der
langfristigen Rüstungsproduktion
Russland wenn es seine Schwächen bei den
Sanktionen überwunden haben wird
mehr produzieren wird können als der
Westen der Ukraine zurzeit gibt und das
zweite ist erhofft natürlich auf Donald
Trump im Weißen Haus und wird sozusagen
das Handtuch nicht werfen bevor er nicht
weiß ob es Donald geschafft hat oder
nicht weil er dann wenn er in den Arm
kommt die Ukraine vielleicht überreicht
bekommt durch den durch Donald Trump der
dann die amerikanische militärische
Unterstützung zurückziehen könnte in dem
Sinn stellt sich die Frage schon jetzt
was machen wir eigentlich nach der
Offensive gibt es im Westen schon klare
Strategie wie wir etwas ukrainische
Ausfälle an Material ist wenn er viele
dieser Panzer die jetzt geliefert worden
sind die werden einfach kaputt gehen ob
die Offensive erfolgreich ist oder nicht
die gehen kaputt weil im direkten
Gefecht Kampf der verbundenen Waffen als
immer zu Ausfällen kommt wir ersetzen
wir die hat sich bis jetzt noch niemand
geäußert
wie hell wie produzieren wir Geräte nach
wenn wir mehr Geräte der Ukraine geben
die Bundeswehr würde auch nicht
sozusagen im Sandkasten spielen und peng
peng schreien
wie können wir die Lieferzeiten für
solche Fahrzeuge wenn die zum Teil zwei
drei Jahre dauern verkürzen indem wir
gemeinschaftlich bestellen all da ist
nur alles noch fliegt Werk viele
einzelne Entscheidungen wenig Mut zu
großen Würfen und das führt leider dazu
das tut ihm nämlich genau an seiner
Strategie festhält er schaut auf die
Europäer sagt okay die sagen zwar im
Fernsehen Interviews sie unterstützen
die Ukraine solange es hält aber sie
haben eigentlich keine wirkliche
verteidigungsindustrielles Strategie wie
sie das als lange sie takes also so
solange es auch brauchen muss wirklich
auszufüllen und deshalb spielt er eben
auf diese langfristig ist Strategie
deshalb ist die Frage wenn es dann nicht
zu Verhandlungen kommt die ist wirklich
gut und auf die kann ich leider keine
vernünftige Antwort geben weil ich aus
unserer westlichen Planung aus dem was
unsere Politiker nicht sagen aber was
sie machen nicht wirklich erschließen
kann wie der besten gedenkt im Herbst
weiter zu machen
danke dass Sie meine und die Frage der
Community so beantwortet haben vielen
Dank schönen Abend noch vielen
herzlichen Dank
ja ihr habt es gemerkt viel ist gerade
noch unklar zum einen was die Miliz wie
die milizwerter Vorgehen wird die
russische zum anderen ob die Offensive
jetzt wirklich schon gestartet hat bzw
in welchem Stadium sie sich befindet
aber ich kann euch eins sagen wir bei
ZDF heute live bleiben für euch dran
danke für eure Kommentare und bis zum
nächsten Mal
[Musik]